cuántos aspectos negativos puede tener
un solo producto el tabaco provoca
cáncer entre otros problemas de salud
sin embargo la organización mundial de
la salud asegura que los cigarrillos no
solo envenenan las personas sino también
el planeta racing all of the force es
una gran causa de deforestación el 5 por
ciento de toda la deforestación es para
plantar trabajos además de los residuos
y cerca de 4 billones y medio de
colillas de cigarrillos terminan en los
ríos mares y los océanos cada año
contaminando cada una 100 litros de agua
lado ms defiende que lo mínimo que
podría hacer la industria tabaquera es
pagar por su contaminación por ejemplo
financiando limpiezas como en francia y
en españa
en francés se ha expandido la conciencia
de la responsabilidad de la industria
productora se cobra a la industria por
las cosas que generan y la industria
paga mucho dinero que puede usarse para
limpiar el medio ambiente y sensibilizar
sobre reciclar los residuos del tabaco
en francia está multado lanzar las
colillas de cigarrillo en el exterior si
este tipo de medidas para controlar los
residuos se aplicarán en varios países
sería un gran avance pero la oms asegura
que no sería suficiente con limitar el
vertido de residuos de tabaco sobre el
medio ambiente porque lo más
contaminante es producir los cigarrillos
en sí por lo que la organización quiere
convencer a los fumadores de todo el
mundo a dejar por completo este mal
hábito